élections municipales encore 22 vols
supplémentaires véritable pont aérien
pour les électeurs obligés de se rendre
sur place
privé de vote par procuration raison de
la grève des fonctionnaires les
nationalistes protestent contre ces
charters électoraux à la haye 24 pays
signent un protocole pour instituer une
haute autorité chargée de lutter contre
la pollution et principalement défendre
la couche d'ozone qui protège la planète
des rayons ultraviolets du soleil
le salon de mars à paris rassemble
actuellement des meubles des tableaux
des sculptures des pièces rares pour le
plaisir des yeux mais aussi pour acheter
car l'art est devenu une valeur sûre
enquête dans ce jour d'hui madame
monsieur bonjour l'oxygène c'est le
passé le présent et l'avenir de l'homme
en se réunissant aujourd'hui à la haye
en hollande
24 pays des cinq continents ont consacré
officiellement l'écologie comme un thème
majeur de la politique internationale de
cette fin de siècle au même titre que
les efforts de désarmement
bien sûr soviétique américains chinois
étaient absents mais tout de même s'il
est suivi d'effet
le document signé cet après-midi marque
le début d'une volonté d'action pour
tenter de préserver notre planète
des méfaits des émanations de fluor
chlore carbone qui s'attaquant à la
couche d'ozone qui protège la terre des
rayons ultraviolets du soleil risque
d'avoir comme conséquence à terme si
rien n'est fait de réchauffer la terre
et de faire monter dangereusement le
niveau des eaux
la haye le reportage de nos envoyés
spéciaux patrick esther yves barbe
le droit de vivre est à la base de tous
les autres sa garantie est un devoir
absolu pour les responsables de tous les
états du monde
c'est par cette phrase que débute la
déclaration signée cet après midi à la
et répondant à l'appel lancé par michel
rocard 24 nations sont tombés d'accord
devant l'urgence de la situation
la planète est en danger l'atmosphère se
réchauffe la détérioration de
l'atmosphère est aujourd'hui certaines
son traitement ne peut par essence 4
mondial ces conséquences peuvent ruiner
les possibilités même de la vie sur la
planète
la france aurait le sentiment d'être
digne des acquis de la révolution dont
elle fait le bicentenaire ci a contribué
en cette fin de siècle à ce qu'une
nouvelle fois la raison des hommes
l'emportent sur le court anarchique des
choses afin que sa firme le droite à la
vie sur les forces de destruction les
rayons du soleil
en arrivant sur terre apportent avec eux
une grande quantité de chaleur une
partie de celle-ci s'évacue en principe
vers l'espace mais depuis quelques
années l'accumulation de gaz carbonique
emprisonne cette chaleur
conséquence le climat se réchauffe
entraînant la désertification des
parties équatoriales et tropicales
la température des mers polaires
augmente provoquant la fonte partielle
des glaces et donc la montée des niveaux
des océans
il n'y a rien de fatal l'homme est en
majeure partie responsables du phénomène
l'homme peut encore y mettre fin par
exemple en réduisant les rejets de gaz
carbonique produit par la combustion de
gaz de pétrole ou de charbon par exemple
également en arrêtant de détruire des
millions d'hectares de forêts ce sont
les arbres en effet qui transforme le
gaz carbonique en oxygène
la déclaration signée alae est une
incitation à la création d'un collège
chargé de surveiller l'equilibre
mondiale en taxant les pays riches qui
polluent beaucoup il deviendrait
possible de verser des subventions
pion aux pays pauvres qui en général
exploite la forêt pour survivre margaret
thatcher qui avait organisé une réunion
à londres la semaine dernière sur le
même thème ne s'est pas jointe à la
réunion se déclarant contre la création
d'une nouvelle institution qui pourrait
nuire à la souveraineté nationale de la
grande-bretagne pour qu'ils soient
véritablement efficace engagements pris
aujourd'hui par 24 pays devrait être
confortée par un vote au mois d'octobre
à l'onu
mais alors on peut se demander pourquoi
autant d'absents aujourd'hui même si on
laisse de côté le cas de la
grande-bretagne
les absents aussi important que les
états unis l'urss et la chine
en france la campagne pour le premier
tour des élections municipales les
terminer officiellement depuis hier soir
minuit
mais ce n'est pas pour autant le calme
avant le vote de demain dimanche en
effet en raison de la grève des
fonctionnaires en corse les électeurs de
la région de bastia notamment n'ont pu
faire parvenir sur place leur
procuration de vote
en conséquence ils sont obligés
d'effectuer eux-mêmes le déplacement et
c'est un véritable pont aérien
d'électeurs qui a été mise en place
entre le continent et les aujourd'hui
seulement 22 vols supplémentaires qui
provoque la colère des nationalistes
corses qui conteste la régularité de ce
qu'ils appellent de véritables charters
électoraux sur place nos envoyés
spéciaux
françoise joly dominique merlet une
bonne partie de la journée
le salon peut se poser les avions de
tourisme à tour de contrôle de vaticane
ne répondait plus aux avions de ligne
car aux commandes de cette tour un
personnel très habituel une vingtaine de
nationalistes corses
motif de leur occupation la trentaine de
vols supplémentaires à destination de
lille ce week-end un week-end pas tout à
fait comme les autres
nous avons su de très bonnes sources et
les autorités ont été saisis aussi bien
le préfet que le procureur de la
république qui avait eu des commandes
massives de billets d'avion pour faire
venir ici des électeurs naturellement
pour
forget le résultat des élections avant
même que le scrutin sera ouvert et nous
avons décidé d'attirer l'attention des
autorités une fois de plus sur la
gravité de ce phénomène
on peut pas parler de suffrage universel
quand tout est prêt par brique et en les
citoyens sont achetés comme du bétail
quand on bat monnayer leur vote
occupation à calais croyez-moi quand on
est près d'arriver et je suis corse et
cantons peuvent arriver sur son sol
natal parce qu'il ya des choses comme ça
mais j'étais absolument nationalistes
ont quitté la tour de contrôle afin
qu'il faut parler avec la préfecture
celle ci a réaffirmé que depuis hier
d'une enquête judiciaire était ouverte
une enquête devra déterminer si des
billets d'avion ont été offerts à des
électeurs élections toujours si dans les
villes de plus de 30 mille habitants le
vote est simple liste sont bloqués vous
choisissez l'une ou l'autre des listes
en présence dans les plus petites
localités c'est à dire l'essentiel
toutes les possibilités de panachage
comme il est convenu de dire sont
proposés sachez que sur les 36 mille
sept cents communes de france 34
millions moins de 3500 habitants c'est
dire que les explications de bruno roger
petit ne sont pas inutiles
demain les français sont invités à élire
leurs conseils municipaux mais ils ne le
feront pas tous de la même façon dans
les communes de plus de 3500 habitants
l'élection a lieu à la proportionnelle
si une liste obtient la majorité absolue
dès le premier tour elle rafle la
majorité des sièges
les sièges restants étant répartis entre
toutes les listes si aucune liste
n'obtient de majorité on procède un
second tour peuvent se maintenir les
listes ayant obtenu 10% des voix et les
fusions de listes sont possibles
la liste qui obtiendra le plus de voix
se verra attribuer la majorité des
sièges au conseil le reste étant là
encore réparti à la proportionnelle
dans ce cas les lecteurs ne peut que
choisir une liste sans sélectionner ses
candidats en revanche dans les communes
de moins de 3500 habitants l'électeur
peut panacher rayer un nom par six en
rajouter un an
reparla bref composer le conseil
municipal dont il rêve dans la limite
des sièges à pourvoir sont élus au
premier tour les candidats obtenant la
majorité absolue et au second tour les
sièges encore vacants iront au mieux
classés enfin pour les lecteurs ces
élections municipales comporteront une
innovation chacun devra signer lui même
après son vote le procès verbal une
innovation destinée à mettre fin aux
pratiques frauduleuses
enfin bien que la campagne électorale
soit donc officiellement est donc
officiellement closes pour vous laisser
24 heures de réflexion avant le premier
tour vous allez entendre maintenant un
appel qui n'a rien d'illégal le comédien
michel creton qui s'est dévoué à la
cause des handicapés qui a obtenu qu'une
loi leur permet de demeurer dans les
institutions spécialisées après leur
majorité s'adresse ce soir aux élus
locaux pour leur demander à eux aussi de
prolonger cet effort michel creton 36000
mère 36000 communes pour moi ce serait
36000 lille il ya plus de 30000
handicapés profond qui n'ont pas de
centres en france
mais je crois que la campagne que j'ai
déclenché l'année passée est devenu un
triomphe par cette loi qui a été voté le
20 décembre
c'est donc devenu une priorité nationale
cette priorité nationale elle doit
devenir une priorité local le maire est
l'homme de confiance
plus loin c'est le premier magistrat
d'une ville qui lance peut aider et à
construire ses centres spécialisés pour
ces polyhandicapés profond ce qu'ils ont
tellement de besoins qui doivent avoir
la dignité
je crois que certains cherchent d'une
carrière de l'autre un destin et bien
chaque commune peut aider à donner un
destin d'une vie
en tout cas du bonheur à ces gens qui en
ont besoin
la suite de l'actualité avec un nouvel
incendie sans doute d'origine criminelle
ce matin dans une cave d'un immeuble hlm
de belfort ou avant-hier souvenez vous
un pyromane avait mis le feu à une
résidence faisant 15 vict le jeune homme
a d'ailleurs été arrêté vous savez il a
été officiellement inculpé ce matin sur
place nous envoyés spéciaux bruno gex
patrick gaubert
5h40 xavier curtet est amené au parquet
de belfort est inculpé par le juge
d'instruction d' incendies volontaires
ayant entraîné la mort deux heures plus
tard il sort du commissariat entouré
d'une trentaine de policiers il porta
gilet pare balles puis s'engouffre dans
le fourgon cellulaire destination
inconnue trois heures plus tôt un
incendie se déclarait dans ce hlm du
glacis le feu a pris dans les caves de
l'immeuble et gagner les conduites de
chauffage des appartements trois
personnes ont été intoxiquées par la
fumée et transporté au centre
hospitalier de belfort
vachon alors j'ai réveillé tout le monde
que j'avais dû pomper et vous avez tout
de suite pensé aux incendies qui s'était
déroulée récemment à une conspiration
qui pensez maintenant maintenant jean
staune être les complices du gain comme
il fut en face de la gare une dizaine d'
incendies certains d'origine criminelle
s'était déjà déclarée dans cette cité
hlm en janvier dernier mais ici à
belfort on ne veut pas céder à la
panique
avec l'arrestation de xavier curtet on
croyait en avoir fini avec cette série
noire
l' incendie de cette nuit relance les
spéculations sur d'éventuels complices
conséquence du redoux cet après-midi
deux avalanches lui n'a pas fait de
victime à mon sapin en savoie une autre
a fait un mort aux contamines montjoie
déclenchée par deux skieurs qui
évoluaient hors des pistes et puis ce
matin à arêches en savoie une plaque de
neige qui s'est brusquement détachées a
tué deux gendarmes et un piste
agnès poirier rien ne laissait présager
l'avalanche de gendarmes est
l'organisateur d'un raid à ce qui était
parti vérifier tôt ce matin les
dispositifs de sécurité sur le parcours
de la course quand une plaque à vent
s'est détaché de la face ouest du massif
et les emporter
malgré la rapidité des secours on était
là tout de suite mais tesco les on n'a
pas pu la trouver tout us dans les cinq
minutes
indécelable à l'oeil nu imprévisible la
plaque à vent est particulièrement
redoutée des alpinistes compact dure une
plaque de neige et de glace peut se
former au dessus de la poudreuse et pèse
parfois de plusieurs dizaines de
centimètres
le soleil la chaleur est brutalement la
plaque se détache et arrache tout sur
son passage
la montagne toujours plus meurtrière
depuis quinze jours dans les alpes
seize personnes ont été emportées par
des avalanches à l'étranger pinnock de
la sphère john towers recalé par les
sénateurs américains qui l'accusaient de
trop aimer les femmes et l'alcool
également il sera remplacé par un
parlementaire monsieur dick cheney en
tant que secrétaire d'état à la défense
il a été présenté par le président bush
il devrait lui sans problème
recevoir l'aval du sénat regain de
tension à la frontière entre les deux
allemagne à berlin très exactement des
garde-frontière est-allemand ont tiré
contre des fugitifs qui tentaient de
passer de l'autre côté du mur
à l'ouest les israéliens qui est au
cours d'élections municipales en israël
la semaine dernière un mouvement
intégriste musulman emporté la victoire
dans une ville et fait élire des
conseillers municipaux dans plusieurs
villages ainsi que dans la localité de
nazareth
jusqu'à présent faut savoir que
l'opposition arabe en israël étaient
laïques et plutôt d'obédience communiste
aux états unis attentat contre la
voiture de la femme du commandant du
croiseur vincennes dont les missiles
souvenez-vous avaient abattu un airbus
iranien civile dans le golfe par chance
madame rogers est sorti indemne de
l'explosion qui a détruit son véhicule
les autorités américaines n'excluent pas
l'hypothèse d'une piste iranienne
jacques violet sharon rodgers l'épousé
du commandant du vincennes le navire de
l'us navy qui avait abattu un airbus
iranien vient d'échapper à un attentat
une bombe a entièrement détruit la
camionnette qu'elle conduisait au moment
de l'explosion
le véhicule était arrêté à un feu rouge
la bombe de fabrication artisanale selon
les premiers éléments de l'enquète
aurait été placé sous le châssis
j'ai entendu l'explosion raconte ce
témoin la femme est sortie de son
véhicule en chancelant et je les portais
jusqu'à mon camion
le capitaine rogers qui commandent
toujours le croiser
vincennes basé aujourd'hui à san diego
avait par erreur tiré un missile en
juillet 88 contre un airbus iranien au
dessus du golfe persique
les 290 passagers et membres d'équipage
avaient été tués
l'attentât contre la voiture de madame
rodgers n'a pas encore été revendiqué
mais aux états unis
beaucoup pensent qu'il pourrait s'agir
d'un acte de représailles contre la
catastrophe de l'airbus iranien si tel
était le cas on pourrait s'attendre à
une montée de la tension au moyen-orient
les américains ne pouvant accepter un
attentat impunis sur le territoire des
etats-unis en tchécoslovaquie la
président gustave ou sac au pouvoir
depuis les événements de 1968 aurait été
frappé d'une crise d'apoplexie son état
serait considérée comme très grave
plusieurs centaines de personnes ont
manifesté cet après midi devant
l'ambassade de chine à paris pour
protester contre la répression actuelle
au tibet les manifestations de ces
dernières semaines n'aurait pas fait
moins d'une vingtaine de morts à lhassa
comme pk assura fille ciellement mais
peut-être une cinquantaine voire une
centaine de vies et la répression
pourrait s'intensifier dans la mesure où
tous les étrangers ont été vous savez
prié de partir il y a trente ans
maintenant que le tibet est redevenu une
province chinoise
jérôme benest image unique du dieu
vivant tibétain le dalaï lama en 1950
alors un jeune homme insouciant de 17 en
recevant l'hommage des lamas dans son
temple interdit de potala pourtant celui
que les tibétains vénèrent comme la
réincarnation du bouddha de la
compassion est déjà dans le collimateur
du tout nouveau gouvernement de maraude
c'est tout comme symbole de croyance
arriérés entretenant un système féodal
sur le toit du monde
octobre 1950 l'armée de libération du
peuple est envoyé à la conquête des
hauts plateaux du tibet pour les soldats
du dalaï lama l'époque des parades en
costume traditionnel est révolu ce sont
des fantasmes qui partent en guerre sans
espoir contre une armée largement
supérieures en nombre ils n'ont aucune
chance
le tibet est occupée par les troupes
communistes
pourtant la résistance armée se poursuit
jusqu'en 1959 le 10 mars de cette année
une manifestation indépendantiste de
30000 hommes à lhassa et réprimer dans
le sang le dalaï lama fui vers l'inde
avec cent mille de ses fidèles
des réfugiés et sympathisants bouddhiste
manifeste à delhi mais le monde
occidental réagi assez mollement à la
mainmise de pékin sur le tibet trente
ans après les tibétains résistent encore
au processus d'assimilation
ils se battent toujours derrière leur
lama pour leur pays où ils sont devenus
minoritaires a fait des transferts
massifs de population chinoise
cette semaine encore à lhassa ce sont
deux cultures antagonistes qui
s'affrontent l'une fondée sur des
valeurs spirituelles l'autre
matérialiste fière de son palais de
dharamsala en inde le dalaï lama a
demandé à deng xiaoping numéro un
chinois de mettre un terme aux violences
qui ensanglantent l'assaut il est
impossible actuellement de faire un
bilan mais c'est certainement le plus
lourd depuis 1959
retour aux problèmes de société français
il ya pratiquement un mois maintenant
les surveillants de prison entamait une
action pour obtenir une revalorisation
de leur profession et notamment de leurs
retraites le gouvernement ne cédant pas
à toutes les revendications peu à peu et
bien le conflit s'était filocher et
malgré une journée prison morte prévue
pour mardi prochain et bien les
surveillants sont aujourd'hui quelque
peu amer nos reporters thiery calmette
pierre laurent constants ont rencontré
l'un d'entre eux en poste dans la prison
de fresnes dans la banlieue parisienne
gardien depuis 12 ans délégué syndical
il témoigne sur son métier qui n'a pas
comme la majorité de ses collègues
d'ailleurs vraiment choisi pas plus que
ses conditions de vie les avantages
c'est de pouvoir aller travailler un
pied et en uniforme les inconvénients
c'est quand on se lève le matin ouvre sa
fenêtre
on voit là présent horizon les murs jean
philippe rémy vit depuis 12 ans mariée
deux enfants ils vont à l'école à 50 m
alors un métier d'avenir
on espère toujours qu'ils feront médecin
ou ministre s'y fait surveillants c'est
un métier comme un autre en tout cas
manens l'assimilent comme un métier
comme à nantes
ce jour là le premier surveillant rémy
travail de 13 heures à 19 heures
horaires décalés une après-midi un matin
et obligatoirement une nuit de garde par
semaine et les tableaux de service se
prépare très peu à la vente apprennent
les conditions de travail constatées
beaucoup de gardiens viennent travailler
en civil dehors l'uniforme du maton
attirerait plus tôt les ennuis alors il
faut bien utiliser le vestiaire
l'administration promet des travaux de
réfection depuis longtemps prise de
service jean philippe rémy comme ses
collègues a débuté à 6400 francs par
mois
aujourd'hui plus de 9000 francs y
compris une prime
disons de risque de 18 100 francs un
simple travail de porte clés ce n'est
plus ce que l'on attend des gardiens de
prison un métier qui sélectionne assez
peu des candidats qui permet de rentrer
dans l'administration après 25 ans mais
devient ton surveillants de prison par
vocation
si je prends mon cas particulier c'est
par inadvertance la plupart de mes
collègues c'est par besoin par nécessité
moi c'est par inadvertance mais il faut
dire que au bout de douze ans j'ai
appris à l'apprécier et
je suis complètement impliqué dedans si
on parle de mauvaise réputation entre
guillemets c'est la mauvaise réputation
des surveillants ou c'est celle de la
prison qui rejaillit sur vous c'est
plutôt celle de la prison parce que je
pense que en millions suivi toute la
journée vous apercevoir président est
comme un père de famille qui travaille
qui rentrent chez eux
comme tout citoyen français une cellule
non une chambre de gardiens célibataire
à l'intérieur de la prison de fresnes
d'autres habitent des logements réservés
loyer 3400 francs par mois avec un bout
de jardin à l'ombre des miradors
autant de situations qui explique la
grogne des gardiens ils ont l'impression
que toutes les réformes profite à ceux
de l'intérieur les criminels et pour eux
les gardiens c'est le mépris de la part
de l'administration au mépris je ne sais
pas je crois plutôt qu'ils ne veulent
pas voir la réalité en face
c'est pas compliqué souffrir hui parce
qu'on nous les idées on les a on y va on
est prêt à contribuer à tout ça on est
prêt à contribuer à ce que la prison
change mais n'ont pas changé d'un seul
côté tout le monde doit en bénéficier
à partir de là tout est possible la
famille rémy nous a demandé de me filmer
ni l'appartement ni les enfants de part
et d'autre des murs toujours un
sentiment d'insécurité et de malaise
économie le bon point de cette semaine
entre dans une catégorie bien spéciale
20 ans après mai 68 on assiste de
nouveau à la vague du retour à la nature
mais il ne s'agit plus aujourd'hui de
vivre en marge de la société
vous allez le voir en ardèche une bande
de copains a fondé une société textile
qui ressemble à s'y méprendre à celles
qui pouvaient exister la même sur ce
lieu même il y a environ un demi siècle
et ça marche reportage de valérie
fourniau et philippe duval l'ardèche une
terre qui n'intéressent plus personne
depuis bien longtemps avec presqu'autant
dame que de moutons un vrai paradis en
1975 pour des gens lassés par les
contraintes de la vie
métro boulot dodo et qui n'ont plus
qu'une envie travailler la laine du
début jusqu'à la fin de la filière
c'était un peu un défi
on est parti de rien il y avait tout à
construire à imaginer il y avait
beaucoup à faire et je pense que c'est
ça qui m'a motivé plus qu'un pari la
volonté de montrer que l'on peut
travailler autrement et réussir en fait
un alliage d'idées communautaire et de
gestion capitaliste avec cette vieille
machine de 1935 récupérer et des
méthodes semi artisanale l'ancienne
filature acheter restauré par une bande
de copains traite aujourd'hui 50 tonnes
de laine chiffre d'affaires de millions
de francs on a démarré cette cette chose
là en étant un petit peu un sac de
qualité avant la lettre c'est à dire
beaucoup de communication beaucoup
d'informations et
on arrive à comme ça prendre des
décisions et à produire dans notre très
bonnes conditions
cette scop se voudrait un exemple de la
réussite tranquille d'une entreprise
locale produire au pays
les spécialités du pays pull matelas
sommiers et couettes une entreprise qui
fait vivre maintenant
agriculteurs de la vallée et que ton 35
min qu'un parent une réussite qui de ce
côté-là aussi n'était pas joué d'avancé
on peut dire que les gens étaient était
plutôt étonné parce que bon les jeunes
lors d'enfants partent et et il se
demandait de quoi des gens qui arrive
est d'ailleurs allé vivre
bon je crois qu'il ya des gens qui sont
arrivés qui sont repartis disons que
c'était plus sérieux est ce qu'on a fait
sous les pavés la plage
qui aurait pu croire que ceux qui ont
quitté la ville afin de se mettre en
marge de la société
ll a recréé dans les moindres détails
avec ses horaires ses contraintes et ses
règles du jeu à la frontière entre
l'économie et l'art le salon de mars qui
ferme demain installée sur le champ de
mars à paris comme son nom l'indiqué on
peut y admirer de très belles oeuvres
tableaux meubles sculpture on peut aussi
les acheter car sachez que l'art est
devenu une valeur refuge et plus sûr que
les actions en bourse en quête de marque
maison neuve et roger moore regarder une
oeuvre d'art quelle qu'elle soit est un
plaisir qui se suffit à lui-même
pourtant certains ont la possibilité
d'assouvir leur passion ils peuvent
acheter cette éléphante mais repris
céphale du 11e siècle enviée par le
musée guimet où cette culture océanienne
en bois du début du siècle
ils ont les moyens d'acheter un million
trois cent mille français seul man ou
ceux mathieu combien coûte cet objet que
je ne saurais que
je demande à millions énormément
d'argent pour un objet dont
l'utilisation ne saute pas aux yeux
vous savez l'objet d'art par définition
l'apa d'utilisation
les clients pensent pas
bien sûr
un million de francs pour un meuble à
magnum de knoll et si le collectionneur
un goût plus classique il peut s'offrir
un de ces trois tableaux de brueghel le
jeune dont les prix varient entre 2 et 3
millions de francs quant à la dame à
l'oeil et peinte en 1530 elle a trouvé
preneur à 600 mille francs
une affaire paraît-il il se trouve que
l'objet avait un bon placement
mais ça ne doit pas être conçue par
comme un investissement
s'il faut pas être spéculateurs seul et
qui veulent spéculer ne sera pas servie
va se tromper à 4 millions pour cette
toile de motherwell il vaut mieux
effectivement ne pas se tromper il se
trouve que maintenant le pré 2
de ses toiles a nettement augmenté mais
c'est une chose qui n'était pas
prévisible et qui sent un petit peu
récente
peut-être un petit peu spéculative mais
ça n'avait rien à voir dans le choix de
défunts l'art flatte les investisseurs
c'est l'exemple de l'effet produit par
monnet sur les japonais et quand en 1974
en pleine crise la caisse de retraite
des cheminots anglais place son argent
dans des antiquités elle prend un gros
risque
je lui demanderais c'est merveilleux
c'est pas tant mais on souhaite presque
la sncf fait la même chose quand on
pense qu'ils ont investi à l'époque 10
millions de livres dans l'art dans
différentes catégories pour solène un
art chinois han impressionniste en
meubles français
aujourd'hui le bénéfice réalisé est
considérable mieux qu'avec n'importe
quel autre placement en france l'oeuvre
d'art est protégé par les règles
fiscales seulement pour réaliser une
importante plus value il faut précédé la
mode
vous pouvez essayer avec wang keeping
sculpteur chinois
ces bois sont eux encore abordage après
l'art tout court
le noble art et 2,2 après rené jacquot
la france possède aujourd'hui un
deuxième champion du monde de boxe dans
la catégorie des super coqs qui reçoit
en effet à limoges fabrice bénichou a
battu le tenant du titre
un venezuela le nouveau champion du
monde français est un boxeur qui sait
aussi parler de son sport et qui avoue
honnêtement qu'il a parfois peur de
monter sur le ring francis maroteaux
andré germa fabrice bénichou boxeur
surnom l'emmerdeur ça rime mais aussi
fabrice bénichou grande gueule mais ça
rime à quoi lorsque l'on ne possède même
pas un titre de champion de france alors
bénichou frappé inconscient sans foi ni
loi
sûrement pas
je crois en dieu je pense qu'ils me dit
on te fait faire parce que tout ce que
je fais c'est parfait par ta voix il me
mène son chemin c'est celui que je suis
et ce chemin là enfin conduit au titre
mondial hier soir à limoges bénichou
champions ubf des super coq
pourtant pour ce petit bonhomme d'un
mètre soixante trois pour 52 kg rien n'a
été vraiment facile jusqu'à présent il
lui a fallu notamment surmonter sa peur
mais même arriver faire dans mon froc
dans le coin du ring avant de partir un
combat pas spécialement d'avoir un
adversaire dur c'est le fait du combat
c'est c'est affreux celui qui dit qui a
pas peur où il est sur humains ou alors
il est anormal
à 24 ans ce garçon né à madrid forêt en
bulgarie seul dehors d'israël et boxer à
panama city savoure enfin sa revanche
après en avoir beaucoup bavé beaucoup
pleuré c'est sur un ring alors
totalement là bas qu'on monte iata est
bon il va boxer alors ils défoncent ils
ces deux mois les six premiers mois je
suis sorti avec une tête comme ça je
pleurais après chaque entraînement je
vivais après rené jacquot fabrice
bénichou donc deuxième titre mondial
pour un français en moins d'un mois
titres dévalués murmurent certains en
raison du chaos actuel de la boxe peut
être mais à qui la faute sûrement pas
ceux qui montent sur le ring
oui le boxeur ivoirien david ciot tombé
dans le coma samedi dernier à l'issue
d'un match qui avait lieu au palais des
sports de lyon est toujours ce soir dans
un état critique
le sport encore avec le championnat de
france de ski des non voyants dans les
alpes aujourd'hui les handicapés sont de
plus en plus nombreux à vouloir vivre
comme les autres et cette compétition de
ski nous en fournit la preuve
reportage de patrick naf et frédéric
basque
un skieur un vrai avec 1 - est un plus
le moins c'est la vue depuis la
naissance stéphane est malvoyante
presque complètement aveugle le plus il
aime la compétition
alors il participe à la descente des
championnats de france handisport sans
se prendre trop au sérieux
vous avez peur quelquefois à depuis la
jeu là je commence à avoir peur parce
qu'on part dans deux minutes et je le
trouillomètre à zéro un peu de vous le
dire
pour ce qui est stéphane est toujours
accompagné de jean marie sans guide
depuis quatre ans je distingue pas grand
chose je ne vois absolument pas le
relief c'est à dire là c'est mes jambes
qui travaille pour mes yeux et puis
quand à jean marie jo distingue sa
silhouette mais c'est pas suffisamment
fiable pour que dans une descente ou
dans un géo ou même dans un spécial je
me méfie se dire qu ils obligés de mener
les indications vocales pour ce que je
déclenche les virages au bon moment ici
et maintenant quatre ou cinq ans que je
me suis vidé par jean marie et je crois
qu'on est au niveau guidage pas loin de
la perfection résultats champion de
france du géant et de la descente mais
dans le slalom c'est l'élimination
pourtant aucune amertume chez stéphane
je suis un mauvais compétiteurs puisque
je n'ai pas vérifié mon matériel avant
de partir et qui m'a lâché en route
c'est à dire que jean marie à une
extinction de voix et au pub le guide et
jusqu'en bas voilà lot de consolation un
petit baptême en aile delta
si on estime la partie vraiment un
handicap quel qu'il soit ce soit en
envoyant handicapés physiques amputés ou
quoi que ce soit c'est de la folie
à ce moment là on reste chez soi et puis
on fait plus rien
l'actualité se termine tristement ce
soir avec la mort d'un comédien second
rôle célèbre de la télévision française
du temps où elle s'appelait le rtf gens
dehors en plus connu sous le nom de
l'inspecteur du puy fidèle adjoint du
commissaire bourrel raymond souplex dans
la fameuse série des cinq dernières
minutes est mort ils étaient âgés de 75
le résultat du tiercé qui se courait cet
après midi pour gagner il fallait jouer
le 1 le 15 et le 3 et ça rapporte 1550
francs pour ce qui concerne le quarté +
c'est bien vous ajoutez le 16 1 15 3 16
et ça rapporte 19 1156 france et 80
centimes voilà ce journal les terminer
tout de suite après bien entendu et les
prévisions météo avec josé devant
lapierre ensuite champs elysées michel
rigueur et pour les toutes dernières
informations et bien aux alentours de
23h30
vous retrouverez philippe gassot je vous
souhaite une excellente soirée et je
vous dis à demain
13h20 soir à demain dimanche